hey youtubers it's Charlie Happy New
Year hopefully you guys have had a
chance to see Star Wars like 10 times by
now but people have finally gotten their
hands on the actual script they used to
shoot the movies so I thought I'd do a
new Easter egg video from stuff that
they didn't really spell out explicitly
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet and just to clarify there
isn't anything in the script that did
not make it to screen there aren't any
deleted scenes this is the script that
ended up being shot all this information
is taken from the final shooting script
that's available at the WGA so if you
remember the writers killed you could
probably walk over there right now and
read it there is a new round of the
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a Fandango gift
card for two movie passes so here we go
biggest thing first the name of the
planet that Luke is on at the end of the
movie now I'm gonna try and avoid
butchering this name because it's a
Hebrew name that sounds like ox - as in
act 2 but the name in Hebrew means
brother so it's just highlighting the
relationship between Leia and Luke that
that's what the brothers meant to imply
I think that's why JJ Abrams named the
plane at that now he is Jewish but
mostly I think it's meant to imply the
importance of the original Jedi Temple
that's on that planet for the next act
of the film the act 2 of the new trilogy
so if you do spell Hebrew maybe you can
help us pronounce this in the comments
next big detail the script clarifies
that Luke knows exactly who Rey is when
she arrives it doesn't specify that she
is his daughter or there's any type of
familial relationship only that he knows
exactly who she is when she shows up I
think I included this next one in my
last Easter Egg video but part of Rey's
forest visions are confirmed to occur in
Cloud City like she's seen Cloud City
when Vader fought Luke the first time
turns out this image here with Luke's
hand on r2 is right after kylo Ren
started burning the Jedi Temple and
killing all the Jedi at Luke's Academy
it does not however specify how long ago
that happened at the timeline these
people surrounding kylo Ren in this
scene in the forest vision also
confirmed to be the other Knights of Ren
I've seen a couple of you guys confused
in the comments there was a line that
Supreme Leader Snoke add when he was
talking to kylo Ren where he said even
you master of the Knights of Ren have
never faced a test like this I think
some of you thought that he said the
asked of the Knights of Brent but he's
just saying that kylo Ren is the leader
of the Knights of Ren presumably we'll
learn more about them in the next film
but one of them is actually gran from
Game of Thrones who's actually a you
know fairly notable actor so we might
actually get to see him with their masks
off next big detail confirmed that Rey
was left with unkar plutt that simon
Pegg's character here because he's kind
of an tour later in the film I'm
guessing that whatever arrangement the
people that left her there or whoever
you know if it was Luke Skywalker or
someone else the payment was only
temporary or he's only doing the bare
minimum make sure that she doesn't die
so just give her enough food to survive
and I'm guessing he and the other people
around there taught her how to scavenge
and that's what she used to survive so
he kind of did help even though he's a
total now he did acquire the
Millennium Falcon that he got it from
the irving boys who stole it from ducain
as han Solo says and the person who Han
Solo was delivering those giant beasts
to when he met Rey and Finn got the
Falcon back sounds like a pretty big
character something similar was
happening in Episode four that person
turned out to be Jabba the Hutt now
obviously Jabba's dead so he's not gonna
be anywhere in this new trilogy
but I'm wondering if this is a really
powerful person that Han Solo was making
the delivery to is going to show up in a
bigger way in the future films like if
he's gonna be a job a type character
without being another Hutt speaking of
Han Solo here's another big one from
later in the script kylo Ren is
horrified by his actions in killing his
father in his somehow weakened by the
act he goes into shock the only thing
that breaks him out of it is Chewbacca's
howl in the bow caster shot so kylo Ren
is physically mentally weakened by this
wicked act not just by the bow caster
and a lot of people were wondering you
know why did Rey beat him so easily
I mean it wasn't really easily she did
have to fight pretty hard but killing
his father weakened him so it did affect
him it's not like he's completely
Darkseid now JJ Abrams made some
comments that made it sound like we
wanted to make it seem like there was no
good left in him but I think that's just
an interpretation I think there is still
good in him that will come out over the
next two films but the script just
specifies that he's profoundly affected
by killing his father not in a good way
not in the way that he hoped he would be
I think what he hoped is that killing
his father would weaken the pull of the
light side and that's not necessarily
what happened in the last big one
Raye in her fight with kylo Ren feels
the pull of the dark side it's kind of
in that moment where he's like you need
a teacher I can train you and then she
rebuffs him strikes him down so she will
probably continue to feel the pull of
the dark side in the next film it'd be
stupid if she didn't but what I'm
expecting is is that Rey and kylo Ren
will be on inverse parallel arcs you see
kylo Ren feel the pull of the light side
you see rave feel the pull of the dark
side it just it just makes sense I'm
always a big fan of symmetry in the
narrative even if it's inverse symmetry
but let me know in the comments what's
your favorite thing that you've learned
about this story since having seen it
when you see it the first time you're
kind of filled with this spectacle but
you watch it a couple more times and you
start to see different details like
what's your favorite thing that you
learned after watching it a couple
different times and just for bragging
rights if any of you have seen the movie
more than four times in the theater let
me know in the comments that's a rare
achievement I don't think I've done that
since I was a little kid I'm still only
at 3 myself right now but I bet I might
go back and see it again it's gonna be a
while before it's that on blu-ray and a
lot of you been asking me about a
potential rogue one trailer there is no
official trailer for rogue one that has
been released
there was a brief teaser they did at d23
but there hasn't been any kind of
trailer the one that's been circulating
is a total fake what I think is gonna
end up happening is that they'll use
Captain America's Civil War to promote
rogue one and Doctor Strange so whenever
that movies are released expect more
Marvel movie trailers and more Star Wars
trailers congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Alec ease you in to star
wars movie passes be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info just in
case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for all my Star Wars Easter
egg videos and you can click here for my
top 10 favorite crazy Star Wars theories
some of them I think are true some of
them I don't think are true thank you so
much for watching though everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you